[Music]
straight ahead
on law and crime daily it's a false
start for the trial of derek chovin
charged in the death of george floyd why
the trial judge is waiting for the
minnesota court of appeals
to rule on how to proceed everything you
need to know about jury selection and
more
in our gavel to gabo coverage attorneys
for the so-called doomsday cult duo
are due back in court our legal analysis
on what to expect
during the latest hearing for laurie
vallo and chad dabo
the search is on for two missing boys
both presumed dead
and thrown into the ohio river the
sheriff who says he won't give up
looking for the bodies of three-year-old
nilo lattimore and six-year-old james
hutchinson
maybe we'll get lucky and find both
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
angela levy is in minneapolis for us to
cover the trial of derek shovin
charged with murdering george floyd jury
selection was set to begin monday
morning
but is now delayed until tuesday so
let's break it all down
derek shobin is facing two charges
second degree unintentional murder and
second degree manslaughter
prosecutors also charged chauvin with
third degree murder
judge peter cahill dismissed the charge
for lack of probable cause
now the minnesota court of appeals says
judge cahill aired
in not reinstating the charge following
the appeals court's
presidential ruling in the case of
another former officer
but as jury selection was set to begin
judge cahill says he doesn't have
jurisdiction
and prosecutors have a stay to
proceedings as we await the higher
court's guidance
we have filed with the court of appeals
a motion to
stay the trial pending resolution of
jurisdiction with the court of appeals
and
in the appeal i believe was just
accepted moments ago
with that i think we really do need to
hear from the court of appeals and they
have not gotten back to you yet
correct we have sent all the jurors home
i think what we were looking for first
is
should we keep going while they consider
the motion
i mean give us a preliminary sign of
should we put the brakes on completely
now while you consider the merits of the
request
first day because that stay is probably
for a much longer time
if it's not clear in our initial motion
that we filed with them
if we do a reply we will try to be very
clear about
sort of that two-step assistance we're
looking for from our court
shop's defense attorney says he's ready
for trial and that the appeal shouldn't
stop the start of jury selection
because the only issue pending in the
appeal is the reinstatement of the
murder in the third degree charge
that means that everything else is is
within the court's jurisdiction
there are two additional charges murder
in the second degree as well as the
manslaughter charge
jury selection motions in lemonade all
of these things can be accomplished
i just wanted to to inform the court
that we're prepared to try this case
it is it is not our intent to cause
delay by filing a pfr with the minnesota
supreme court
however um i feel i have an ethical
obligation to my client
and to other criminal defendants to do
so because it was a published published
or excuse me
presidential opinion
that's what's going on in the courtroom
angenette levy is here to fill us in
on what's going on outside the
courthouse
yeah brian you know the day started out
with a protest
by a bunch of rally-goers social justice
groups
seating is limited here at the hennepin
county courtroom because
of the or the courthouse because of the
covet 19 pandemic
so people are really showing their
support for george floyd by gathering
outside
and holding rallies in the streets
they're keeping track of what's going on
by watching live streams and
keeping track of social media now
members of george floyd's family have
been given
one seat in the courtroom floyd's sister
bridget floyd occupied that seat
on the first day now while court is in
session
protesters filled the area around the
courthouse and the streets
bridget floyd said afterwards that it
was hard to be in the courtroom with
derrick chauvin and that she and her
family
need and appreciate the community's
support now there hasn't been any show
of support for derrick chauvin outside
of the courthouse
there are people supporting him online
though jury selection will resume on
tuesday morning
the judge said he will bring in 14
jurors on tuesday
seven of those will be in the morning
and seven will be in the afternoon for
questioning by attorneys from both sides
brian
thanks antoinette here to break down the
first day of jury selection the trial of
the murder of george floyd
is law and crime host jesse weber and
terry austin jesse
jury selection without knowing what the
charges are is that a problem or is that
something that can i don't know be
figured out as they go
well it becomes a question that was
really interesting today from what we
heard from the judge because i said how
many times do you have a case
where you're prosecuting somebody for
murder and then you have the whole case
go through and at the end of the day
at the end of the trial you say how
about we include the lesser includeds
now
and is that really that different from
what we have here and i'd say it really
is
different i don't think that you can
start this trial
without knowing the third degree murder
charge that is
very different than second-degree murder
and very different than second-degree
manslaughter so i was of the camp
surprised to see the judge wanting to
push forward with this
without a definitive answer on that
charge yeah and we'll see how that plays
out because
the way they're planning it out they
used to have three weeks to then panel
this jury
now terry what did the judge mean about
not having jurisdiction how's that
playing out
well you know technically judge cahill
has jurisdiction over the trial
but he doesn't have jurisdiction over
this specific
issue of the appeal and the issue
currently appeal
on appeal rather is this third degree
murder charge and whether or not that
should be
reinstated and it doesn't really make
sense to go forward on more substantive
issues like
actually in my opinion jury selection
but i think certain motions evidentiary
emotions
could go forward but the judge is being
careful he wants to hear what the court
of appeals says
and he wants to wait for them to say yes
you can go forward on these various
issues like jury selection now angela is
it correct that not a single person was
questioned today
do you get a sense the case is moving
along in any way shape or form
not one single juror was brought into
the courtroom to be questioned
at all both sides argued for that or
against it the prosecution did not want
any of the jurors questioned until they
could tell the jurors definitively what
charges derek chovin would be facing
so the judge said at the end of the day
that he wants to move forward
it is his plan to start jury selection
on tuesday
but he is going to wait for the court of
appeals before proceeding because
no one wants to create an appellate
issue if is a conviction
in this case and they can't retry it
obviously
if he derek chovin were to be acquitted
because of double jeopardy
exactly well hopefully the court of
appeals is listening and we can
keep up with this case as it goes on
thank you everyone
still ahead on law and crime daily
what's next for the doomsday cult duel
laurie vallo and chad dabal but first
back in the courtroom for the derrick
chauvin trial
attorneys reach pre-trial agreements
while they wait for the court of appeals
ruling
our legal analysis after the break
[Music]
barricades barbed wire and fortified
fencing the sights
surrounding the courthouse in
minneapolis where derek shoving is
scheduled to stand trial
for the murder of george floyd the
national guard along with the state
and local law enforcement have descended
upon the city preparing for unrest
but as angenette levy tells us not all
are happy with the ramped up security
yeah that's right brian you know
businesses here in downtown minneapolis
some have actually closed others have
boarded up windows preparing for any
unrest that could happen during this
trial and
as you can see behind me there is a
double ring of fencing
around the hennepin county courthouse
now the national guard is also here at
the courthouse with armed members behind
the fencing with armored trucks
there are concerns about violence after
the unrest last year following the death
of george floyd and some of the
protesters say
they feel like the fencing sends a
message that derek chauvin will be
acquitted before the trial even starts
i think that people are entitled to
public trials
and i think that um acting like somehow
um you know we can't behave responsibly
um to observe these trials and so forth
and that we have to be
you know not just kept out of the
government center but kept off the
property around it that this is our
property um with these you know multiple
layers of chain
fences and razor wire i think it really
um
suggests to people that there might be
that there might not be justice in this
case a lot of people say to me
you know they put these fences up
because they're planning to let this guy
off
and i think a lot of people believe that
and city and county officials here in
minneapolis have said that they're just
trying to be prepared
for anything they've used what happened
at the u.s capitol on january 6th as a
prime example
they estimate here that the city and the
county have spent about 1 million
dollars on security measures
brian thanks anjanet and in court both
sides agreed to a number of conditions
including not allowing witnesses to
watch
live streaming of the trial and
preparing or sorry and referring to
floyd
and shovin by their names not victim and
defendants
i think it is most appropriate because i
think it's most respectful
to refer to people by their names so for
example
not victim or deceased but as
george floyd for example i think it is
much more respectful
to call people that way but however i
also
don't want to micromanage the language
used by council
if there is a reasonable basis in the
record to say so
so i actually do allow the state to save
victim
i do allow the uh defense to say
something other than that
to describe for example in this case mr
floyd
i do allow the state to use the term
defendant
and mr nelson i'm sure will use mr
chauvin
back to talk derrick showman in jury
selection as long crimes jesse weber and
co-host
terry austin terry what did you make of
these motions in lemonade were there any
conditions that stood out to you i think
all of the conditions
made complete sense i mean if you think
about it one of the conditions was
they did not want the witnesses to look
at any live stream
and if you think about when you are in
court witnesses aren't allowed to see
other witnesses so i think that's
very consistent with what would happen
if everyone were
in the courtroom and so also i think it
does make sense to call the parties by
their names the judge said he wasn't
going to demand it
but if they agreed to call each other by
their names other than
victim or defendant it is more
respectful and frankly it can be a
little derogatory
when you say the victim and when you say
the defendant so so far
from what we've seen i think all of this
makes complete sense
jesse let's kind of touch on that point
there was a lot of agreement between the
sides and the motions eliminated like
let's talk exactly about that victim and
defendant you don't hear that type of
agreement in rape cases or other murder
cases
should we be reading into both sides
agreeing so much
no let me tell you something if today
was any inclination
i don't think this is going to be smooth
sailing for the weeks and maybe months
to come because these are two sides that
are
basically at odds in what could be
arguably be
the most important and high profile
trial we've seen in 20 years
i really think that this is a sign of
nothing i think
both sides are going to be back and by
the way both sides are excellent legal
counsel and i think that you are going
to see
fireworks as soon as this trial
ultimately starts i think you're going
to see it with jury selection
i don't think whatever you saw today
whatever agreement is a sign of things
to come
now angenette what should we be
expecting for the second day of jury
selection are we going to start seeing
those fireworks
perhaps as jesse is suggesting
you know i think we very well could if
jury selection begins
remember we're still waiting to hear
from the court of appeals
the judge said he wants to forward with
the questioning the voidier process
with the potential jurors but we have to
wait and see what the court of appeals
says the judge wanted to go
forward today and felt that he had the
legal wherewithal the right to do so but
the
prosecution wanted to hold off on that
all right court of appeals the ball is
in your court we're all waiting and
hoping to see what happens next
thank you all be sure to tune in to the
law and crime network for capital gavel
coverage of derek sherwin's trial
still ahead on law and crime daily the
search for two missing boys in ohio
continues what's making the search
difficult plus
the prosecution is making demands from
the doomsday occult duo
as the duo tries to move the trial
[Music]
welcome back attorneys for the so-called
doomsday cult duo are due back in court
and this time it's the prosecutors who
are making the demands taylor austin
breaks down what to expect
at this latest court hearing for lori
valo and chad davil
prosecutor wood is asking the judge to
order attorneys for the couple to hand
over a survey they created
saying it should be entered into
evidence lori valo and her husband chad
day bell are charged with concealing and
destroying evidence
while valo's children were reported
missing authorities discovered the
bodies of j.j and tyler ryan buried in
shallow graves on daebel's property
the defense wants to move their trial to
another county
saying they won't be able to get an
impartial jury in fremont county
chad dabel's attorney conducted a poll
as proof
for why the defense says a change of
venue is needed
now wood wants to see the survey for
himself
requesting that it be filed into the
court record
let's bring in law encrimes jesse weber
and terry austin to discuss the latest
in lorry vallo and chad dabo's case
terry this seems like an easy request
the survey supports
a change of venue give it to opposing
council in the court
so what's the big deal exactly brian you
know
if the survey in fact supports a change
of venue
why is the defense withholding the
evidence i think that perhaps
the problem is in the questions and
maybe the defense
doesn't want the judge to see those
questions because
the risk is that the court could review
these questions in the survey and they
could rule that they were biased or
looking for certain answers
and maybe the survey will be you know
dismissed and maybe
the fact that the venue will stay
exactly what it is
it's odd brian i don't know why they
would object to this
particularly when they are the ones who
took the survey yeah jesse as a public
defender i kind of
giggled when i first heard this imagine
you don't have to share this
information you could just tell the
other side hey i did this survey we're
supposed to change venues
i don't need to show you anything that'd
be a crazy i would love it but that
would be a crazy rule
why are we lawyers then why are we
lawyers we have to prove
everything there's be no such thing as
evidence you can't just say
this is what i want trust me it's a good
decision that's not the way the legal
system works and especially in this kind
of case
which is incredibly high profile and
there is a lot riding on it to make a
serious decision like a change of venue
you better give some proof about why
that's the case now i can't say i'm not
surprised because i've seen
the defense and the prosecution
throughout this case
highly antagonistic remember it was the
defense who wanted to kick
rob wood off this case so i don't i
probably think this is a sign for more
things to come as this trial
go gets further further towards that
trial definitely getting heated asking
for things but hey
i can't show you my notes we'll see how
that plays out thank you both
when we come back an update on the
search for two missing boys in ohio the
lengths one local sheriff and an entire
community
are taking to try to find their bodies
next
[Music]
we're back an ohio sheriff is speaking
out after searches for two missing boys
in two separate cases
have yielded no results
three-year-old nylon lattimore has been
missing since december his mother's
boyfriend desean brown
is charged with murdering her after
police found her body in a bag
along the ohio river prosecutors say a
nearby stroller belonged to neticia and
nilo lattimore
and believe brown also killed the little
boy now
surge crews are also looking for
six-year-old james hutchinson
his mother brittany gosney reported him
missing in late february
police say she later confessed to
killing him and throwing his body in the
ohio river
investigators believe she was pressured
by her boyfriend james hamilton
butler county sheriff richard jones says
high water levels
have made the searches challenging
it's very difficult the way i understand
it the searchers aren't going to get in
the water
it's too dangerous it's still too high
but that's where we're using the aerial
the the sheriff's helicopter and they're
uh going over the river up and down the
banks
uh we have uh uh our equipment there
so they can have a command post they i
don't believe they're going to be
anybody
in the water today but because it's it's
it's so high yet
but they're going to look along the
banks they're going to look on top
with the helicopter maybe the drone use
also
it's very difficult but when you have a
six-year-old the body's been thrown in
water it's so devastating
and people are so angry over this child
be thrown in the river
we want to do all we can to help
brittany gosney has been indicted on
charges of murder and kidnapping
investigators are hoping her alleged
confession will give vital clues
to help find her son's body
everybody's on high alert but
it depends on the temperatures of the
water what happens to the human body
and i don't want to get very graphic as
we're talking
but the temperatures of the water the
temperature above the water
and how the body reacts uh you you fill
up with air you float
there's details that i cannot give uh of
what exactly took place
uh we're trying to find the body but
you know where the body is located if
we're fortunate uh the body would be on
the side of the bank
uh or up floating where we can find the
child
it's multiple jurisdictions uh to where
uh the crimes took place it apparently
it appears
it started in treble county ended up
in butler county and then ended up in
uh on the ohio river i believe it's uh
lawrenceburg in indiana so there's lots
of multiple jurisdictions
the way i understand it the butler
county prosecutor's office
is uh is in charge of
the prosecution and that's not unusual
it happens when there's multiple
jurisdictions involved
back one last time is terry austin for
analysis terry
as you're hearing the sheriff describe
the struggles of searching for these
children they're they're searching 21
miles of the bank
no one's going in the water because the
water levels are so high are you hopeful
that we'll be able to find these two
young boys are you
are you kind of i don't know a little
heartbroken that this might end up
um worse than not find them
it's difficult ryan this is the ohio
river you're looking for two small
bodies one
is three one is six and they're doing
the best that they can
i think that obviously if we can find
these bodies it'll bring some closure to
the families
but at this point it's been days i think
it's going to be very difficult
water runs fast and you heard the
sheriff they're talking it's
it's a very difficult search now terry i
like the fact that you brought up the
word closure i know you and i have had
this conversation before because you
watched so many of these trials
where we've seen past cases where the
defendant admits guilt and gives
information
to the officers to help them find the
body for a lesser sentence
do you think in either of these cases
that should be something the prosecutors
should be
considering absolutely not not for
either one of these cases because they
were so heinous and we're talking about
young children so i think they should
get the maximum gotcha thank you terry
and thank you for joining us here at
long crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you